you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on Lee chest
org and I just got paired up playing a
15-2 game
let's try Knight f6 as a start
all right c4 well I probably play the
nimzo-indian or try for it too much so
let's try something else here like c5
and see how white replies oh very modest
move a couple things running through my
mind I have to be too concerned about
the bishop coming out here no pins what
more I could go for a fee and ket oh
yeah I'm leaning I'm leaning towards
this g6 and the other candidate moves
I'm sure there are
but yeah I like this idea I'm not going
to commit any of my center pawns just
yet so let's get these couple standard
moves in and see how things develop
they could play d5 and grab some space
but they're holding off on that
probably just castle if ever capture I
have a check and I could quickly pick it
up yeah let's start with the castle and
maybe in the end I capture I open up the
door for the bishop but I could then
follow up with d5 and potentially saddle
white with an isolated Queen pond so
let's consider this is a big moment I
imagine that the top move here is to
capture on d4 I'm just doing a scan
right now to see if there's any other
hmm productive move here for black what
concerns me about deploying my knight to
c6 is d5 and then d6 which really puts a
dent in my structure I'm not so much
concerned about the loss of a pond
because I could still play Queen a5 and
scoop him up it doesn't have to hit with
check a queen on a5 there isn't a good
way to defend the pawn on c5 I think I
have to take here you know I think
taking his best with in d5 slower moves
like b6 there's d5 and my bishops
getting shut down yeah I should probably
just capture and I'm expecting pawn
takes and now I have to challenge this
pawn duo immediately open the door for
the bishop at the same time
I'll be looking to unmask my dark square
bishop
most natural way to do that is 94 two
birds with one stone
opening up the bishops eyes improving
the night so no Knight c3 expected that
probably knight c6 you know let's get
knight c6 in
square bishop
we'll see
in this position I feel like well that's
a big decision made pretty quick too and
grab some space on the queenside
okay well let's look at the drawback
connected with that move
there's no no longer as much pressure on
d5 so I think I could jump right into e4
right now
hmm for some reason I'm recalling maybe
a game I played as white here against
the computer not certain of that know
something I'm recalling in this position
from somewhere something close to it
so other than Knight to e4 not sure what
else to consider this is an idea to try
and challenge this space invader pond
but this leaves my knight vulnerable so
I could see one of these two moves
hitting and that feels a bit awkward to
loosening let's just say it's true that
they can't support it with v4 but again
my Knights vulnerable
so let's see
it probably is Knight to e4 on 94 Knight
takes pawn takes I'll be winning this
guy yeah I think I should jump in right
now and if he isn't defended or if he
isn't captured right now maybe I could
consider a 5 maybe Queen B 3 Knight a5
Queen takes pawn is losing because of
Knight takes Knight Queen takes Queen
Knight takes bishop check and only then
the recapture on d8
I'm vulnerable a little bit more on d5
so Bishop f4
okay
well this concerns me a little bit at
the same time maybe I could try and chip
away at this guy here on d4 suppose I
just you know following White's
footsteps here and develop my fourth
minor piece Bishop g4 looking to take
out the knight and then take on d4
hmm Wow
it could happen that all minor pieces
are exchanged so there's a lot there's
really a lot to consider here on Bishop
g4 95
hmm now that I don't think that that
would be working Bishop g4 95
I think I could take on e - and then
yeah I have pressure on c5 so I could
take twice here pull this pawn away and
then take on c5 Bishop g4 95 Bishop
takes Bishop if Queen takes I could take
on d4 immediately and hit the queen yeah
I'm still hesitant to play b6 here
I am leaning towards Bishop g4
I'd be okay with investing my bishop
pair or my light-square bishop let's
just say I didn't really don't see
anything wrong with that let's give it a
go
Bishop g4 it is another instant move
coming up or I think this time
a little bit of a think good to see okay
so how are they addressing this pressure
against d4 that's right here's to take
and then take again don't know that I'm
winning material but I'll be the first
one to strike
you know I'll win the pond first and
then maybe there's a way they could get
it back like my deep on or something
but you know what about the rooks
neither of us have our rooks
in the ballgame yet
not a hundred percent sure where they
belong just yet so I think this is a
position that requires a bit more
clarity I'd like some more information
about mmm well I'd like to see let's say
some pawn captures you know if there's a
completely open file okay
my rooks are probably gonna go there I
have a flight square it's not the
greatest flight square but if somehow
he's exchanged for this guy and it's a
heavy piece ending I like that you know
I have already a square whereas white
still needs to invest a move and that
move might be right around the corner so
I feel like I've made some success with
those last two moves
you know nightie and they played Bishop
f4 I go 94 and now the bishop goes to e3
so now what
hmm well I could take the night and then
play e5
there to be a little bit careful this
bishop is unprotected so there are some
some potential tricks connected with e5
takes Bishop takes Knight takes Bishop
takes Queen Knight takes Queen there's a
lot to calculate there if I want to play
e5 that is
I don't think there's any tricks
connected with the d4 push with the fork
let's look at the most direct type moves
as I now go under seven minutes I think
takes Knight pawn takes
be five then no this is way to weakening
don't like that idea
v6 right now hmm
v6 Queen b3 Knight a5 if I go be six and
there's Bishop b5 what could I do and
reply to that just rip to c8
it seems like it should be sufficient if
this bishop ever you know if they come
over here I could I could take that
night out
b6 pawn takes pawn takes my queen as a
responsibility hmm okay looking at b6
and one more
I really have much more to look at I'm
gonna try it
that is weakening I have to strike and
with one of these two yeah this this
leaves it vulnerable if I play e5 I'd
like to win this pawn instead of a trade
let's go b6 there
it's the final verdict I want to win the
d4 pawn I don't want to exchange it for
my pond so this is this is clearly uh
something White House to defend right I
mean Bishop f4 Bishop e3
okay now I have to take what the pond hi
Brooks happy
an immediate question to my light-square
bishop
okay I feel like I have a winning idea
no not quite
Bishop takes Bishop takes Knight takes
Knight no I do have an idea yeah I think
I'm going to end up with an excellent
structure very very soon Bishop takes
Knight Bishop takes Bishop Knight takes
Knight B takes in Knight a5 stopping c4
does the move order matter I don't think
so
yeah move order probably doesn't matter
I'll take the knight first yeah this is
a backward pawn I'm going to look to
target it
let's take out the night and night a
five and I'll soon be playing east six
so I have one week pawn in the position
B six whereas white has two week ponds
yeah so this is really the big struggle
at this stage it's related to pawn
structure I don't see the bishop pair as
a great positive for white my knight
might be so much of a bother tries to
get rid of it and even in a heavy piece
ending alone this is a pretty good so I
guess they're preparing to trade dark
square bishop
I think I want to in the event that
Bishop h6 is played I want to be able to
win something so let's put a media
pressure on their weak point
c3 if I need more support for b6 my
knight will satisfy that really can't
say enough about a knight on the C 4
square in this position but I'm gonna
hold off even though it's a tempting
square to jump right in to I'm gonna
hold off on going there because while he
while he is positioned well there he
they're moving very fast let's get this
moving he would be masking the rook from
seeing c3
so now I don't have to worry about this
pond anymore my queen is free to do some
some more exciting things
if I win c3 then d4 is the next target
I'd like to see the a pond and the be
pond exchange somehow if I could get rid
of this a pond that would be great
so if I do need some more support okay
let's see
maybe maybe night see for right now
drive a better move
let's go tonight see for you know what I
don't want Bishop b5 I don't want to see
in Bishop to b5 and then let's say a for
definitely taking with the rook I want
to keep pressure here so now it's good
versus bad Bishop situation
Alki well probably rook to c6 just
defend b6 for a bit don't give him away
so easily I want to get my F rook
working
yeah let's do this just queen bee five
if I go here maybe that invites Bishop
f4 deflecting my queen away from the
defense of the rook well first things
first I could go here now there is no
pressure on my rook I'm just looking for
one of these two and my bishop may even
reroute let's go here so my queen is
free of the defense of my rook
maybe this they don't have a great well
neither of us I don't think how the
greatest of off light squares
they're both dark some both still
working with the dark square bishop
let's see they go for something like
this again that would be great I'd love
to see these guys exchange they are
going for that hmm well let's do this
a better flight square for my king
I may look for this type of reposition
yeah I think I want my bishop on d6 so
let's do that
you
and I want to go after this guy just yet
I give up my beep on and then they have
a past a pond I don't want this exchange
just keep my eyes peeled for tactics
especially trying to exploit their back
rank I don't want this bid Bishop to
sneak in by way of f6 so on this move on
planning King g7 Bishop here now there's
maybe even some sacrifices okay King is
on a light square I'm just gonna get
another quick move in he's off the back
rank very long-term if there's ever
promotion it's now not hitting with
check basically what I'm thinking about
there
and now
well you know what I have the safer King
with that last move they just
they're really inviting h4 yeah
this was their last key defender for
their Kings side and while the action
was really taking place on the Queen
side here now now there's going to be
action on the Kings side now that the EF
pawn is no longer so I'm just looking to
smash away
I'm takes and then take here possibly g5
okay let's just take for starters and I
could even play rook h8 to h5 I don't
know that I want to do this because it
weakens my King and I think there's a
slower and quite an effective approach
in that of rook h5 to h4
let's just do it without too much
thought
I'm on the pond
this records too far
smashed through at c3 by this point I'm
okay with this type of exchange because
I'm going after the king okay
so maybe maybe I could do this let me
just calculate a little bit or know I
could do this adding a third piece yeah
I'm gonna I want to keep this right here
g6 g6 f7 structure there's all
weaknesses within whites camp I only
have one weak link I have a nice pawn
island of for this queen leaves pressure
on my rook my queen will be free to
maybe sneak into f5 if this Queen is
pulled back to let's say defend okay or
similar but first things first
rook f4
prepare for queen g4 how about we do how
we do this move like c4
it's looking to win the a for pawn how's
that defended can't go with the rook if
you go with this rook I take him I think
I'm winning the a pawn
Rick b2 rook takes pawn rook takes pawn
rook takes here I probably have some win
even if I give up my bishop have this as
an idea I'd like to do this one is much
more clear right now it's no good less
than two yeah as soon as the rook gets
here this bishops pinned and then
there's this idea all right now that
pawn could be one soon it feels yeah
go straight after it can't defend h4 now
there's too many weaknesses h4 c 3 a 4 f
4 no home for the king and tall upon
syndrome very tempting as mentioned the
g5 move ok probably just take with the
rook yep good look at the h2 square
something like this I have good defense
now with my bishop on the 7th rank if
this pawn is ever one he's not struck
out
so it feels while he may at some point
be unprotected if my queen gets active
you know I still feel that this is a
secure square can't really get Adam so
easily okay
just win another phone
I don't see any reason not to well Queen
check I didn't even see that idea
okay well gotta take hmm I'm up to pawns
but huh I didn't see that
okay while they save their king with
that I felt like I should have been
getting mate and my wreck feels a little
out of play ah didn't even see that idea
that's why the bishop was backing up so
I probably should have done Bishop d6
then with the safer King I mean yeah I
wanted to keep Queens on the board there
he's kind of out of play I know cow what
is that Bishop - and how about this for
starters you know to be careful
still I'm many pieces on dark squares
rook h1 if the bishop moves actually
rook here is threatening a check
winning my rook okay
interesting
okay I'm gonna drop back and I really
shocked me that Queen check this is
dragging on much longer than it should
have
hmm okay I'd like to see the dark square
bishop scum off oak I guess we'll get a
trade in there
there's some more pieces traded off my
King feels a little bit more comfortable
coming over in this direction let's pin
the pawn okay I should come over on this
side trying to blitz me out
maybe the rook on that five is pretty
good I'm being sneaky right now Rick
takes bishop there in pre-move mode
actually this is a winning idea you know
even if they play here I go here if they
get out of the pin I just take Fisher to
d8 rook here put them in a pin keep them
independent till they get out of it on
push rook takes Bishop King takes Bishop
g5 incoming they're in the think tank
plying on
okay let's just get over here
give a check I want to trade one pawn
just so these don't they don't start
rolling okay
bishops defending that guy just I'm
banker I guess
let's render like this mm-hmm oh no is
that gonna be repetition oh my goodness
it's repetition oh my goodness
man that was awful
unexpected into that one
and just as I said it I thought it might
be repetition and it was oh my goodness
okay that's not a cool ending at all hmm
let's go into the analysis
well that really stinks to say it oh
okay let's go to the analysis and see
what we could still learn about that
middle game I like the structure that I
got from that clearly I had some targets
and I was putting pressure on them
what the analysis to its thing mmm that
game almost feels worse than a loss yeah
I think it does
let's see quiet start modest modest idea
with III and I guess we are following
some games huh
94 Bishop f4 Bishop g4 okay let's see
what the analysis is saying yeah
guess I could convert
that ending better where that rook
wasn't even getting active it should
have been mate somehow you know with the
safer King just keep Queens on but I
totally overlooked the Queen e5 move
just a couple more seconds because it's
just even even even and then from move
what after King g7 yeah soon as they
played F form that's the big shift right
there King g7 I played and then when
they played f4 they no longer had a home
for their King so that was the big the
big issue in the game you know b6 let me
just put the analysis straight on b6 is
okay and he moves like this Queen d7 is
a move that's a little bit scary I must
say
you know going into this pin and they
take snowy pawn takes oh wow
queen g4 heading for me that's pretty
slick and then that's okay you'd have to
see something like that though because
otherwise if this mate thread isn't
there then this is pretty devastating
winning or capturing the knight and then
hitting with a fork mm-hmm okay so they
probably should have done something a
little bit different here instead of
Bishop f4 yeah it's suggesting Bishop to
e3 I guess we could kind of make that
out by the game you know we should have
for Bishop g4 Bishop e3 so some time was
wasted that's an easy way correction to
make b6 and now I could go straight in
how I played it it's one of these
positions where I have the targets to
play against and they have to crawl up
into a ball to defend let's see if there
was a more clear-cut way to finish this
game off before it even got into that
ending yeah so they have to do something
other than f4 still struggle
Bishop g5 I could look to a target
either pond you know putting the rook on
c4 get something going there now that's
a computer line so okay after King g7
they played f4
take look at this look at this reading
negative 3.9 I could go and 4g5 right
away but there are many different
approaches and I still I still would
play it how I did here with rook h5 not
pushing my Jeep on I just don't want to
allow any counter play against my king
for as long as the Queen's are on the
board
Roxy for h4 what am i up now just one
pawn you know
Bishop d6 just killed that idea and then
go after the King with the Queen's on
board
but you know something I mean clearly
something was lost here allowing the
Queen's off and this is a really
annoying pawn - you know because he
clamps down on these guys for as long as
there's more pieces on board and I'm not
so comfortable with you know getting
these guys rolling as soon as we had a
rook off
I was fine to get my king a bit more
active by repetition I'm not the only
one that that's happened to is it okay
so clearly winning ending how could I
have done things better here what would
be the winning plan
suggest to push this guy I just want it
I want to do it really clean honor what
would be the best approach here I did
think about this you know I have my
bishop defending boats but and then I
this kind of ran through my mind I can
probably run it like that maybe this is
a pretty clean clean way to do it mm-hmm
not so much I would be fine like I'm I'm
really close to just being in a position
where I could sack my bishop for the
pawn but I don't know my rook isn't the
greatest piece he should probably be
behind the pawn so maybe I could pull
something like that off like right now
check get here and then get behind the
pawn check King's somewhere bishop here
and maybe even it's okay to drop that
pawn right well now I have moves like
that but just to show let's say Bishop
here rook takes pawn and now I could get
marching with this so this is the ideal
mm configuration let's just say the
definitely wants to be behind the be
behind the pond I have some coordination
with my pawn and Bishop there's maybe
even a slower approach like King here
and then doing this you know this pawn
actually isn't going to go as a step
further because I could capture it and a
route right around this point even
invest my bishop for the pawn because
I'd be winning the King and pawn ending
so this seems like the clean approach
instead of the little repetition but
yeah just to get my rook behind the pawn
right here and give this guy up I don't
need to defend both one is good enough
and I could just win it from there okay
well definitely an unexpected ending to
that one and fortunate repetition there
at the end but as usual feel free to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comment section below and as always I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye